DALE MARKOWITZ: So here on
"Making With Machine Learning,"
I record all my
videos in English,
because it's the only
language that I speak.
But you guys?
You're from all over
the world and you speak
a lot of different languages.
Right now, we do
translate it as subs,
but I wondered if we could
use AI to translate it dubs.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
DALE MARKOWITZ: I got this idea
from my extremely inspiring
co-worker here at
Google named Markku.
A couple of months ago,
Markku filmed a YouTube video
showing you how you could create
real-time translated subtitles
that would actually be
projected on your body,
and even helped me
build my own version.
So I thought, OK.
He did speech to
text, but why not
add AI text-to-speech
like an AI voice actor?
Now, I know a lot of
you said in the comments
you hate computer voices.
SPEAKER 1: But I don't
mind them at all.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So
here's how I did it.
This project is actually
kind of straightforward.
First, I'll pull the
audio out of my videos
and then I'll use
the Speech-to-Text
API to transcribe them.
Next, I'll use the
Translation API
to convert the transcripts
to any language that I want.
And then finally, I'll use the
Text-to-Speech API to speak
those translated transcripts.
OK, so the first step is to
enable some Google Cloud APIs.
For this project, we'll
need the Speech-to-Text API,
the Text-to-Speech API,
and the Translation API.
I decided to do this
project in Python,
and you can find all of my
code in the Making with Machine
Learning GitHub repo.
First, I use a library
called pydub to extract
the audio from the video
file and save it as a wav.
Next, I temporarily uploaded
that file to the cloud
so that it could be used
with the Speech to Text API.
Here's where I actually call
the Google Cloud Speech-to-Text
Client.
There are a couple
of different ways
that you can configure this API.
First, you specify
the language_code,
which is what language
you're transcribing from.
enable_automatic_punctuation
tells
the API to look out
for punctuation,
like question marks or periods.
enable_word_time_offsets
gives you
both the word and the
exact time the speaker
said them. diarization_config
tells the API to look out
for multiple speakers.
And you also have the ability
to use enhanced, more accurate
models for certain languages.
By the way, here's
an example of what
the data that actually comes
out of that API looks like.
Next, we have to chunk
the transcript output
so that we can feed it
to the Translation API.
At first, I thought
I could do this
by splitting words into
sentences based on punctuation
mark, and then translating
each individual sentence.
But then, like a dummy,
I realized that that only
works for Romance languages.
And in Japanese, you can't
just split sentences by period.
So instead, I had
to check for gaps
in when the speaker started
and stopped speaking.
And then those were
the chunks that I
passed to the Translation API.
Actually calling the
Translation API only takes
a couple of lines of code.
Here's what the results
of the Translation API
look like on my transcripts.
Finally, I called the
Text-to-Speech API
to speak the translated words.
You can configure the API to
use different computer voices,
and you can control the
speaking rate, which
I used to make sure that
the computer voice sped
up or slowed down
to match the rate
of the speaker in the video.
SPEAKER 1: Sometimes,
I talk very fast.
And sometimes, I talk more slow.
DALE MARKOWITZ: OK, so it's
about midnight right now,
but I just got all of the
individual pieces of the dubber
working.
So I'm going to try it
off for the first time.
MARKKU: [SPEAKING FINNISH]
SPEAKER 2: Welcome to the
no time testing center shed.
We are here collecting
learning and various sports
using this picture scooter.
So send the helicopter into the
air and start collecting data.
DALE MARKOWITZ: There
are actually two places
where errors could come from.
First of all, the Speech-to-Text
API could make a mistake.
It could mishear me
and mistranscibe me.
But also, translation
can be inaccurate.
So I'm going to show
you two approaches
to upping the accuracy.
First, we can up the quality
of Speech-to-Text by using
a feature called phraseHints.
Here, you can specify
words or phrases
that you think are more
likely to appear in the video,
and then the API will be more
likely to recognize them,
especially if they're uncommon
words or proper nouns.
For translation, we
can use something
called a glossary,
which is just a CSV that
specifies the way we want
certain words or phrases to be
translated.
For example, in Markku's
video, the translations
for drone and tarp
were a little off.
So even though Markku
said tarp in Finnish,
the API was
translating it to shed.
Using a glossary, we can
make spot fixes like this.
Putting these two
tools together,
I was able to make the accuracy
of the dubs a lot better.
They're not perfect, but
here's what they sound like.
SPEAKER 2: Welcome to the AI
coach testing center tarp.
We are here to collect learning
data on various sports using
this image scooter.
So send the drone into the
air and start collecting data.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Let's listen
to a few other examples.
MARKKU: [SPEAKING FINNISH]
SPEAKER 2: I have to make
a New Year's resolution
to eat less treats
and play more sports.
SPEAKER 3: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER 4: There
have been companies,
non-profit organizations,
and educational institutes.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So
I always thought
it would make sense to
take something simpler,
like software engineering.
SPEAKER 5: [SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
DALE MARKOWITZ:
What do you think?
Would you watch one of
these AI-dubbed videos?
Let me know in the
comments below.
And I'll see you next time.